[Music]
are you ready for the uk transition
number one buying from or selling to the
eu
hello my name is jane rose and i'm head
of international trade at the essex
chambers of commerce
we've created four bite size videos
about the uk transition
or brexit these have been commissioned
by rochford district council
to help businesses prepare for the
changes to trading with the eu
we will be covering buying from or
selling goods to the eu
key dates and stages what to do to
prepare to continue trading with eu from
january
and finally where to find resources and
support to help you get ready
there are web links and references
listed in the video description
in this video i'll be talking about what
will happen if you buy goods from or
sell products to
the eu so let's get started
as you'll be aware we are no longer in
the eu and on the 31st of december
2020 the current transition period will
end
you've probably heard this mentioned so
many times but what does this actually
mean for your business
well up until the 31st of january you'll
be able to carry on buying and selling
goods
to and from the eu in the same way that
you do now
but from the 1st of january that will
all change
the transition period will end and there
will be a uk customs border between the
uk
and the eu to put it simply when you're
buying and selling goods to and from the
eu it will be classed as exporting
and importing this is the same as
trading with say
the middle east or india you may have
heard in the news about a free trade
agreement between the uk
and eu regardless of whether there is
agreement between the two parties
the way you trade with the eu will
change from the 1st of january
so if you haven't already done so you
need to prepare now
here are some action points to get you
started on your preparations
meet with key people in your business
make sure that they understand
there will be changes that will affect
the business
it's a good idea to start by assessing
what you buy from and sell to the eu
then get some in-house knowledge or
training on customs processes
review your existing processes and
future requirements
it's important to learn about customs
declarations
as this is the single biggest
requirement and change impacting how you
will trade with eu
and how the eu will trade with the uk
you'll need to find out how to classify
your goods using the new uk global
tariff and exporters trade tool
it's important to speak with your
logistics and transport providers
as there are changes and new
requirements for them too
lastly speak with your eu customers and
suppliers
are they prepared it's important to know
as they'll have to make similar
preparations for trade to go ahead
smoothly
we know there are a lot of essex
businesses that are well versed with
exporting worldwide
but it's very different to trading with
the eu so i can't stress enough that you
need to plan ahead
it will take time to understand what you
need to do but once you've got the hang
of it
you'll be able to import and export
globally and make the most of your
trading opportunities
however if you do nothing your goods
will not be allowed to pass through the
border
and your business will be disrupted so i
do urge you to act now
the government have introduced three
stages to the process to help you
prepare
they're based around three key dates the
first of january the first of april
and the first of july 2021. in the next
video we'll take a closer look at what
these key dates mean for you
please do contact us at the essex
chambers if you need our help
and explore the web links in the video
description for further information
thank you so much for listening
[Music]
you